everybody has a brand or they are
invisible your brand is the story people
tell themselves about you and the
expectations they have of what you're
going to be like when you walk in the
room
when it comes to creativity marketing
writing and how to interpret the world
few names are as influential as that of
today's guest Seth goat if you are a
pizza lover and you think about the
great pizza places in the United States
none of them are full-service
restaurants
you have to say this is what I do
because
then you have an excuse for everything
being sort of average
through his work including books like
tribes Purple Cow and this is marketing
Seth seeks to turn people's lights on
Inspire them into action and teach them
how to level up and in this conversation
he certainly delivers on that endeavor
so I had 20 best sellers in a row and
not one of them has sold to more than
one percent of us
which means that 99 of us populations
said not not interested no idea who you
are see ya that's not failure that's
success we discussed navigating creative
blocks the distinction between marketing
and advertising and his most recent book
the carbon Almanac a One-Stop shop on
everything we know have known and
potentially will know about global
climate change what we've been doing for
110 years is selling
carbon-based energy way cheaper than we
should we forgot to count how much it
really costs it was an absolute dream to
have Seth in the studio I've looked up
to this man for a very long time and I
think they're going to be really
inspired by our exchange so this is me
and the Great South Dakota
so many things to talk about indeed it's
such an honor and a pleasure to have you
here today I've been looking forward to
this for a very long time and on the
subject of too many things to talk about
this is the challenge with you Mr Seth
Godin because you are truly such a
polymath uh and wise on so many topics
with this breadth of expertise that you
know spans a myriad of disciplines that
it's very difficult to choose which
thread to pull and I have deemed this
condition this disease polymath induced
podcast host paralysis uh-oh yes soon
I'd be in the DSM to be clear to be
clear I don't have that much expertise
but I'm good at asking questions about
the way things work I think that's a
very humble answer because I do think
that you are very wise
across so many disciplines
and I was reflecting on the drive over
here today about the fact that and I
think this is a good way to launch in
um
that are
email I don't know if you remember this
but our email correspondence about
trying to make this happen dates back
many years through a mutual friend Matt
Frazier who introduced us many years ago
and you said listen when you're in New
York I'm happy to do the podcast come up
to my home in in Hastings on Hudson
right and I did not take you up on that
offer this is a like a heuristic or a
rule like if you really want to have you
know podcast you will get on the train
from Manhattan and come up and uh I did
not do that and the story that I've told
myself about that because I've reflected
back on that many times is that I was
too busy I had a packed schedule I just
couldn't afford the time so I was rooted
out in your rule but that's not really
the truth I think the truth is that I
was
frightened by the prospect of meeting
you I was intimidated you're somebody on
hold in such high regard and I did not
feel up to the task I was
um succumbing to insecurity and uh
perhaps
um a sense of perfectionism paralysis
that prevented me from rising to that
challenge I'm so sorry that certainly
wasn't my intent I feel all in my head
well but it's all in all of our heads
and it's my loss because we could have
had two podcasts instead of one this is
true uh but I also believe that these
things happen when they're meant to
happen uh and I I I now feel armed and
ready in a way that maybe I didn't back
then
um but I think that that subject of of
feeling paralyzed or not feeling up to
the task with respect to a creative
expression very much falls in the the
focus of many of the things that that
you pontificate on so eloquently
so I don't know that that's a question
but perhaps it's definitely a launching
point it's an epidemic
um so I wanted the story I wanted to
start by telling you happened to me a
couple days ago
I was in San Clemente uh seeing a friend
and got up at six o'clock in the morning
to go for a swim
I almost drowned I am a good swimmer but
I have never experienced the current the
way that I did
and it was this moment of
it doesn't matter whether I'm swimming
with 10 people or no people there's not
there's nobody who's gonna help me but
me
and this moment of this might be my last
thing what do I want to do right now
and it's there's a lot of things left to
be done
there's a lot of work left to be done
people to connect with ideas to share
and I just took a deep breath and
motored in barely
and I think
it's worth talking about that because
there's a huge difference
between drowning off the coast of San
Clemente and putting up a blog post that
isn't perfect or
um
connecting with a customer or a friend
in a way that you wish you could do it
differently the next time
and yet we've been pushed to make
everything a matter of life or death
when there aren't that many things that
are actually matters right
so in that Moment of clarity when you
felt death being visited upon you you
had this uh uh you know sense that there
was much left to do and to kind of get
out of your own your own way as somebody
who's very good at getting out of their
own way
it was
extraordinary how quickly all the
Imposter syndrome stuff goes away
because I like I'm sitting there saying
well I can't swim nearly as well it's
rich but it didn't matter because I
wasn't in a race with you I was just
trying to get back to Shore and in that
moment you become the best version of
yourself which is usually good enough
yeah
um on the on the the topic of of
creative expression
um the Titans that come to mind are
people like Julia Cameron uh who wrote
the artist's way Stephen pressfield
Robert McKee who I just had in here who
was a hoot
um now Rick Rubin have you read his new
I was the first person to read it oh you
were I I got an early copy of it because
I was doing an event with him a Google
event with him a Fireside uh and read
that book and was just deeply moved by
that I think it's you know
soon to be as it is released into the
world uh among the great uh books on on
Creative expression and I would consider
your work very much in that regard as
well and I would be remiss on a very
selfish level to not you know run a
little bit of an experiment on my own
creative blocks as somebody who who you
know is in the business of creative
expression
um really the last real book that I
wrote was in 2012 and there's an
argument to be made that all of this the
beautiful studio and the podcast and all
of it is a massive elaborate distraction
and and justification or rationalization
for not getting up and writing every day
and this is my Mount Everest that I'm
determined to conquer in the upcoming
year and I think what's interesting
about it is that
you know reflecting on my own boundaries
as being somewhat porous and and very
much negotiable I have a self-awareness
around it and I'm aware that these
habits will not change without a system
change and yet despite that
self-awareness and the parlance of
recovery like self-awareness will Avail
you nothing it's the action that that uh
that moves the needle and in my
experience
as somebody who's undergone you know
dramatic changes over the course of my
life those changes are generally
motivated by pain when I feel backed
into a corner and the pain of my current
situation
um finally chips over and exceeds the
fear of that change
well that last part's good I want to
throw a monkey wrench in just a little
bit maybe for our listeners and not for
you
I'm I think Steve and I would agree on
this just because there's resistance
doesn't mean the thing you are feeling
resistance about is important
and what you have been doing for the
last 10 years is narrating a journey for
millions of people
you haven't been hiding working at a
baba tea shop you have been showing up
with a unique voice for people who need
to hear it in a medium that didn't exist
25 years ago and Jessica's books have
been around for 500 years and there's a
particular pain that comes from writing
one because of the proustian overhead
that goes with it doesn't mean that you
will serve the people you seek to serve
better by writing a book now if it turns
out that the conditions that you need to
write a book will actually escalate your
thinking in ways that can lead you to
where you want to go then I'm all in and
I would love to help you but it could be
that this is resistance
bothering you
pretending to be resistant saying you're
a failure because you haven't written a
book go write a book but that's actually
keeping you from pioneering a new kind
of Netflix talk show or whatever it is
that's going to let you do your unique
work so I don't know the answer to that
yeah no I mean it's a it's a it's a
valid observation and I think that uh
perhaps I hang my hat on this idea of of
where being a published author
um sits in the hierarchy of influence
and there is something about that that I
think is real I think it's being uh
challenged and fractured it's eroding
really yeah it's not what it used to be
um but I do think that
fundamentally I feel like I am a writer
and I haven't served that Muse inside of
me yeah so it's a it's a function of
like getting honest with myself and
trying to dissect what are the
externalities those external kind of
social pressures that I feel to live up
to a certain standard versus what is the
best use of my time and energy and it is
true that
this podcast reaches more people than
any book that I'm going to write on a
weekly basis so from that perspective
there's no reason to write a book
because I'm already communicating with
more people if that is an important like
variable in that equation but books as
you know with your love of books stand
the test of time and there is something
about that three-dimensional thing that
exists in the world that I think is
important and Timeless and hopefully
will remain so yeah so
thank you for teaming up first the
discussion about the marathon which is
the difference between people who run 20
and 26 miles isn't physical condition
it is simply
figuring out where to put the tired
that the people who finished figure out
where to put the tired and the people
who don't don't because if you made it
to 20 you could make it to 26.
and you can't go to a trainer and say
please train me to run a marathon
without getting tired it's not an option
so if you're going to do important work
as a writer
you can't say I want to do important
work as a writer but not feel any of the
feelings that come from doing important
work because that's the deal that's why
writing is worth doing
but that doesn't mean you have to do it
the way Ernest Hemingway would do it
and there are lots of ways to create the
conditions for you to have
a place where the best work is evoked
and so I've coached a lot of friends to
writing books some of which I've done
very well and the first rule is you
can't become attached to the outcome
that publishing is a weird business
that's more of a hobby and it has all
these signals in it that don't make
sense great books don't sell that well
biology books sell a lot of copies
good people spend their lives promoting
books that's not what you need to do so
we're not going to get attached to
whether it's a bestseller we're going to
get focused on did this book be what I
wanted
but then the second part of it is
getting really clear about who's it for
and what's it for who exactly are we
seeking to change and if you're not
clear about that you're going to write a
mediocre book no matter what it is but
you can visualize the emotional state
fears the dreams the desires the person
you're seeking to serve in the book
becomes much more practical for you to
be able to say this works and this
doesn't and then the last thing comes
from Isaac Asimov who I used to work
with when I was a kid and he was old uh
he invented the idea of robots he was
one of the most successful science
fiction authors ever
and
um Isaac published 400 books in his
lifetime
that's unbelievable unbelievable and I'm
sitting in his apartment near Lincoln
Center in New York and I said so Isaac
he had a pretty big ego he liked when I
said things like you've written some of
the most important books of all time and
you've done 400 books how did you do
that and he walks me over to this little
tiny table with a manual typewriter on
it he says what I do is I wake up in the
morning and I walk over to this
typewriter and I type from 6 30 to noon
every day and it doesn't matter if it's
good I just have to type
and that thinking
tricked his subconscious into typing
good stuff because it feels really
stupid to sit there and tell you bad
stuff
and so what I say to people in the 2020s
is you don't need a manual typewriter
you need a recorder and then you need to
find a human being you want to teach
something to
and go for a walk with them and record
you for an hour telling them what they
need to know hmm then get it transcribed
and start with that because you can make
that better but that just did the hard
part right which is you got over blank
pages now off the table correct yeah
yeah I mean the idea of creating that
non-negotiable and then lowering the
stakes seems to be the path forward
um but taking a step back from that it's
really all about boundaries and knowing
how to say no to protect your U.S right
yep and this is something I know that
you've thought about deeply that you
practice and you teach to so many people
so talk a little bit about you know how
you create those rules around the things
that are important in your life and then
maybe as background to that how did you
figure out what was important to you
so
um if you are a pizza lover and you
think about the great pizza places in
the United States none of them are
full-service restaurants with big menus
they make a thing and they make it the
best they can make it because it must be
done with care or it becomes mediocre
and we have created an entire generation
of wandering generalities as ziggs would
say instead of meaningful specifics
and to be a meaningful specific you have
to say this is what I do you can say and
and and and because then you have an
excuse for everything being sort of
average and if your slogan is you can
pick anyone and where anyone then
someone else is going to win you want to
be in and of yourself the one and only
version of that
so I think that's a universal law I
think that if somebody is more focused
than you they're going to put in more
Cycles than you and they're going to
learn more than you and inevitably
they're going to become better than you
when you have enough competitors so with
that said
you got to say well the only way that's
going to happen is if I say no to all
sorts of attractive things
so in my case as somebody who has a
certain kind of willpower
it means uh
no Twitter No Instagram no Facebook no
LinkedIn uh almost no travel and there
are all these things I don't do
because I don't want to reconsider every
time because it would be a huge number
of Cycles to say oh that but this one's
really special I should open the door
and think about that one again but is
this a function of not wanting to fall
into the kind of uh pleasure trap of
scrolling or is it because you don't
want to be influenced by what other
people are saying I'm not only I'm not
reading them but I'm also not writing on
those platforms so when Twitter came
along it was early days I saw it I said
I could probably have a lot of people
following me on Twitter yeah but if I
got good at Twitter I would have to
become mediocre blogging
so I don't want to do that I want to be
really good at the thing I do and not do
the other things that's part A and yes
as you pointed out listening to
Anonymous trolls makes nobody better
I've never met an author who said I read
all my one star reviews on Amazon and
now I'm a better writer so 11 years ago
I stopped reading my reviews on Amazon I
haven't read a review Once since that
day because I'm not going to learn
anything from one star review other than
it wasn't for me well you just told me
about you but you didn't tell me about
my work so I get it it wasn't for you
but that's not what I need to learn to
get better
I think many people fall into this
illusion that whatever they're creating
is for everybody and they don't have
that Clarity around who specifically
they're writing for or creating for and
as a result the work suffers right and
this is something this is a drum you've
been beating you know from the beginning
about you know all the way back to
tribes Etc
um about like having that definitive
sense of who you're serving and I think
we're in an interesting time now because
the internet has fractured the
monoculture and everything is about
tribes now they're
is it's very unlikely that we're gonna
see you know only rarely now do we see
gigantic creative offerings that move
the entire culture yes and because of
that it's created opportunity for many
people but I feel like people still fall
under the delusion that they need to be
like Taylor Swift or George Lucas or
somebody like that Taylor Swift
appreciating yeah
this is such
an easy thing to describe and a hard
thing to embrace
so about seven miles from here is a Four
Mile Trail where you can go in a state
park into the woods and find out where
they filmed Mash like you're in the DMV
backyard Trail it's a real I was there
yesterday and I took pictures and sent
them back to the family and my wife's
like that's really cool
and the kid's like what's this
so Mash was the most popular TV show
ever broadcast when it went off the air
the last episode 70 million plus people
saw it so to compare 70 million people
to a show like The Sopranos or Mad Men
or whatever which got seen by three
million people when they were broadcast
right one twentieth the number
or if you think about anything that your
friends people in quotation marks are
talking about on Netflix a million two
million people are seeing it when it's
first coming out Taylor Swift would not
make the Billboard top 500 if her music
was compared to sales from the 1970s not
even close that what it means to win on
the long tail is it's a tiny drip in a
giant bucket and that's enough
so I had 20 best sellers in a row and
not one of them has sold to more than
one percent of the US population which
means that 99 of the US population said
not not interested no idea who you are
see ya that's not failure that's success
so writing for all these people who are
never going to engage with you making a
TV show or a podcast for everyone
no don't don't make cereal because
cereal ends up being popular because
something had to win that day's Lottery
but it's probably not going to be you no
and it's very specific in what it is I
don't I I don't think anybody involved
in that program anticipated the success
nor were they making it for the purpose
of impacting culture on a mass level
right but if you copy them and say well
this is going to be the next blank
you've lost why you're doing it the
threat you're saying someone's going to
win the lottery it's going to be me and
we see struggling people struggling with
income tricked into buying lottery
tickets for that very reason and it's a
dumb investment and instead put
ourselves on the hook and say no I'm
making this for you know the vegan
community of Agora Hills California and
if they don't like it I have failed
because it's for them and that's who
it's for so I put myself on the hook
when I say that whereas if I say I'm
making the best thing I can and
hopefully lots of people will like it
well then when a few people don't like
it you can just say well I'm waiting for
the next people I'm waiting for a lucky
break how do I hype this
and so putting yourself on the hook
that's how you get funding for your
project that's how you hire people
that's how you get a job be specific not
this average mediocre generalist right
and and backing into that talk a little
bit about how you made these decisions
for yourself about how
um you wanted to invest your time and
and kind of defining for yourself what
was important to you
so
um I failed a lot when I was getting
started 10 years in a row pretty much I
got 800 rejection letters in a row from
the book publishing Community after I
sold my first book chip Conley was
co-author in 1986. yeah I want to get
into the chip Conley Seth Godin
Algonquin Table back in the anthropology
department and and so Chip and I sold
the first one the first day I was like
oh I get it I'll just make books that
everyone wants to buy and Publishers
will publish them
and what I discovered was that the
market was smarter than me and it was
saying to me we get that you have ideas
about what book would sell if it was at
the cash register at Barnes and Noble
but we can't make a book get to the cash
register at Barnes Noble through will
it's luck so why don't you make
something specific
and that pushed me on this path of
realizing that every time I got deep
with things and it wasn't always the
same thing from my team there were 10 of
us but you know we did the Stanley
Kaplan SAT prep books not sort of
average SAT prep books we did novels
based on Nintendo games the best
Nintendo games not something we could do
easily or conveniently and that cycle
got it started and then I started one of
the very first internet companies and
what was going on in the internet in the
90s was
think about how we spend our time today
and imagine that none of those companies
existed
so there's this huge race because it was
a buffet for a few of us who understood
what was happening and if you put too
much on your plate it all fell off and
the people who figured it out put one
thing on their plate and won that thing
so I understood strategically what was
going on but then the personal challenge
was
um I don't as an entrepreneur like
getting too close to I'm gonna have to
give this up and go get a job as a bank
teller so conservative about the size of
the risks I was taking
but also I have mild add and oh look a
puppy I'm mildly distracted by shiny
objects and I realized if I didn't put
up blinders I would be racing from one
thing to the other so those were the two
reasons that got me disciplined but
within that there's this journey I mean
you're at Stanford Business School
you're iterating on all these business
ideas you from there become a Serial
entrepreneur you have an exit and you
get into book publishing Etc but at some
point you decide I'm going to be a
writer along the way you learn all these
skills these you know relevant
principles around business and culture
and there must have been an Impulse to
share them was that a function of being
in the book publishing industry and
saying actually I could write better
books than this or where did the writer
impulse you know come up and and make
its voice heard for you
all right so when I was a book packager
I did 120 books some of them what is a
book packager I don't even know that if
I know what that is it's like being a
movie producer
you create the conditions for a book to
exist most books don't need one almanacs
need one encyclopedias need one uh photo
books need one because it's a production
and
um
sometimes I wrote them sometimes I
didn't usually I hired other people to
write them but I wasn't a writer with a
capital w I would go to meetings and the
editors would treat me with much less
respect because they like writers they
didn't like people who did what I did
and when I was building the internet
company yoyodine it was taking us six to
nine months to close the sale because it
was complicated in those days to explain
what permission marketing was what email
marketing was I was like hey I know how
to make books so I write a book about
this and we could just give the book to
people which would give credibility and
if they read the book the sales cycle so
it's totally a mercenary thing to say
this would pay off for our company but
between the time I wrote it and the time
it came out we sold the company to Yahoo
and yet this book came out and it became
a New York Times bestseller
and around that time some things
happened in my personal life my mom got
really sick uh I left Yahoo I moved back
to New York and I sat in a dark room by
myself for nine months
not with no job with why bother writing
another book my real book worked I can't
sell more copies than that and then this
guy who almost no one had heard of named
Malcolm Gladwell sent me the galleys of
a book called The Tipping Point
and he asked me to blurb the back of it
and uh I read it in an hour
and I sent him a blurb right away and in
the next two weeks I wrote an entire
book because clearly I had been thinking
about it but had been denying resistance
doing it because I didn't want to be an
author I thought
but Malcolm's book opened that spigot
for me because I saw that he was
committing a generous act yeah in the
way he was describing what he was seeing
that's so interesting because I do think
of you in in similar terms as people who
um
have a keen observational ability when
it comes to seeing Trends from a macro
perspective culturally business
Etc
and have kind of you know not
necessarily contrarian but kind of
orthogonal perspectives we were talking
before the podcast about your ideas
about how to you know uh reframe the
Olympics Etc I mean these are all you
know these These are there is a shared
kind of Kindred sensibility there yeah
yeah there is and I'm always flattered
if someone Compares me to Malcolm except
when it comes to hairstyles because I
used to have hair like he's the champion
but it all fell out anyway so I was
nervous because my book was going to
come out before his and it had been
inspired by the idea so I sent it to him
and I said if you don't think I should
publish this I won't
um but if you like it I appreciate any
kind he actually volunteered and wrote
the forward for it which he doesn't do
anymore but that was back in the day and
the book was about how I did spread so I
put the book online for free
and
I just needed to get it off my desk I
didn't I had been using books as a tool
my whole career I love books but I did
it wasn't an author in the sense of I'm
willing to slave and obscurity to put my
stuff down they were a tool they were
what I did for a living
and this book I wasn't gonna make a
penny from I just wanted to share this
idea because it was so Timely
and it took off it got downloaded
millions of times the most popular book
of all time at the time I was like oh
well we should make a hard copy because
people hate reading it on the screens in
you know 1990 whatever 2000 so we
quickly made a hardcover and it became a
really big bestseller I was like now I'm
an author because now I've done it twice
in a row and not only that I'm not
sitting in a dark room by myself anymore
this this cycle of think hard write hard
and a year later your event publishing
event will happen and then you can do it
again I can do that and I can do that
with the sense of confidence and
generosity right that is partly because
I understand the industry partly because
I know how to write even though I didn't
used to know how to write I taught
myself and partly
um because
I think I can see systems in a way that
people would appreciate yeah and so
that's what made me a writer so today
when somebody says to you oh they don't
know you they've just met you and they
say what do you do do you answer that
you're a writer or how do you like what
do you write on forms where they say
occupation
I've got it to my friend
um he has a great 10-minute talk about
the elevator pitch
but my rejoinder is no one ever bought
anything on an elevator
and if you're busy doing an elevator
pitch it's probably a way of hiding I
think elevator questions are better
because what you want is people to
follow you out of the elevator and keep
talking to you and so when people ask me
what I do uh I now say I'm a teacher
because I've do it in enough media that
I don't think of myself as just an
author
um but the uh
I've always had a lot of insecurity
about picking that genre because
imposter syndrome instantly follows
Julie what would you say to somebody who
comes to you and says you know what I
find your lifestyle or the way that you
eat really aspirational but I'm too busy
I just don't have time I don't want to
be cracking open cookbooks and trying to
learn a new skill when I'm already
exhausted after a long day how do you
guide this person where should they go
the plant power meal planner is really
really such an amazing value it is under
two dollars a week and for that it gives
you this inspiration know-how and
thousands of recipes to create the
plant-based meals that you crave in your
own life so it's so amazing to be able
to log on to the plant power meal
planner and get the recipes the
ingredients the shopping list and then
the support from all of the coaches that
we have available to answer all of your
questions so join us in eating more
healthy vibrant plant-based meals and to
kick start our health intentions this
New Year we're offering you twenty
dollars off a one-year membership with
the code power 20 throughout the entire
month of January to learn more and to
sign up go to
meals.richroll.com again that's promo
code power 20 for 20 off at meals Dot
richroll.com
[Laughter]
so as somebody who who you know is known
as a a genius of marketing you're in the
marketing Hall of Fame uh
how does how does marketing play into
how you think about what you do and how
you kind of ship your creative work to
use your vernacular
um
you know do you think about like the
brand of Seth Godin and the promise and
the trust that you're building with the
community of people that care about what
you do
okay so small sidebar for people who
haven't listened to me for 400 hours
before marketing isn't advertising
marketing isn't hype marketing isn't
hustling people no one wants to be
hustled it used to be all of those
things in 1965 advertising and marketing
were the same thing I'm not sure I
understand the difference well
advertising is using money to interrupt
people so you make enough money so you
can do it again
and in the age of mass marketing
average stuff promoted a lot will always
outsell average stuff that's not
promoted a lot so Skippy peanut butter
and Heinz ketchup and go down the list
those are intentionally built to be
average
they respond well to advertising
but the internet like all things it
blows it up and it says
name any brand you care about and trust
these days their ad budgets either
non-existent or tiny right when's the
last time you saw an ad with a jingle
for Google Google doesn't have a jingle
they don't need a jingle so it has been
replaced by the story We Tell to the
people we seek to serve so that
the story is
resonant and they will tell the others
if you can do that
then you have done a good job of
marketing
and so if we think about you know how do
you go about marketing at Toyota Prius
well first thing is make sure it doesn't
look like a Toyota Corolla
because if it looked just like a Corolla
as they were driving around the
neighborhood no one would notice them
but if you have a car 10 years ago that
looks a little bit like a weird
spaceship your neighbors you know and so
you start to understand status roles and
affiliation and dominance and
subcultures and tribes and all of these
things are what marketing actually is
the story We Tell
that creates tension so that people will
move forward that's great marketing or a
story that's being told that invites and
attracts people who like that story and
would like part of that story to be
their own story correct it starts to
create identity which is about
affiliation or either you're an Insider
or you're an outsider culture is right
next to marketing so I've been a
marketer my whole life and everybody who
has been successful at making any sort
of change has likely been a marketer if
they're dealing with voluntary
interaction right so if you want
um
uh soccer to be more popular than
basketball in a country you need to make
marketing decisions that have nothing to
do with whether you're putting up
Billboards and a lot of people don't
understand this they think they just
need to get some more money together to
put up some more Billboards which used
to be true but it's not true anymore
and so when we if you you know if you
drive down uh through Hollywood you see
all these Billboards for not very good
TV shows that aren't going to resonate
with people that's because someone at
Netflix or Hulu is making bad marketing
choices about what shows to make and who
to put in them not bad marking decisions
about billboard please
so with all that said
everybody has a brand or they are
invisible
your brand is not your logo though your
logo is very cool your brand is the
story people tell themselves about you
and the expectations they have of what
you're going to be like when you walk in
the room
that's your brand
and if you start becoming inconsistent
your brand will inevitably become
inconsistent and fade away so General
Motors doesn't have much of a brand
because we don't know what to expect the
next time General Motors tells us
they're going to make a car whereas
Mclaren has a brand no ads but they have
a brand because if I said I got a new
car from McLaren you would have a hunch
sure as to what I spend on it and what
it would mean about me identity wise
which is why I have to take great pains
is that I don't have a McLaren right so
I would be very surprised exactly
because that's what a brand is so in my
case
there are definitely times when I would
like to act authentically in the moment
and I don't because authenticity is
overrated your customers don't want you
to be authentic your podcast listeners
don't want you to be authentic they want
you to be the best version of you that
you promised them
that there are certain professions like
Rockstar where you get points for having
a meltdown on stage and dying of an
overdose because that's authentic but in
most other fields if you go to see a
doctor for a checkup you don't care that
the doctor is having a bad day you just
want her to be the best version of that
doctor that she is capable of being
today because that's what you bought
and so
you know when you see somebody having a
tantrum dealing with a customer service
person that's you know
unacceptable it is a a a version of
status roles that I don't approve of but
also if that person who is having the
tension with someone you knew their
brand would change in your mind sure all
right well a couple observations on that
first of all
you know I do feel like this innate
allergy to the idea that like I'm a
brand like I I really struggle with that
I understand intellectually the
importance of thinking about this in a
professional context and the role that
brand plays in that but it's It just
strikes me as distasteful and perhaps
that's because you don't have to like it
it's a whole economy of you know what's
going on on the internet right now
um and then and then second to that I
would push back a little bit on and I'm
interested in your thoughts on this on
the authenticity piece because I do feel
like authenticity is an aspect of what I
am communicating and and advocating
through the work that I do because I
feel like most people are are so far shy
of being authentic to who they are and I
have to model that I don't have to I
choose to model that in a in a way
that's perhaps a little bit more
vulnerable than somebody else who does
what I do to create that permissiveness
for the audience now I calibrate that
I'm not going to come in and you know
like I I'm choosing those moments not
not in a negative context of strategy
but you know there's there's there is
too much vulnerability and too much
authenticity I would grant you that so
it's a spectrum we're not disagreeing
that we have no problem with the fact
that Alana Glazer plays a role when
she's on television we're not looking
for the authentic a lot of glaze we're
looking for a Broad City a lot of Grace
or Jerry Seinfeld or George Costanza
whatever you want right
and all the way at the Other Extreme we
want our spouse to talk to us like the
authentic human being that they are so
everywhere in between is a spectrum if
we get pulled over for a traffic ticket
we don't want the cop to punch Us in the
nose just because they can and they're
having a bad day not okay it would be
authentic but not okay the last time we
were fully authentic we were a year old
and we had poop in our diapers ever
since then we've been calculating we've
been trading we've been saying I know I
could blurt something out right now but
I'm going to hold back for just 10
seconds because it's worth it and what
I'm just trying to let people say to
people is I don't want to let you off
the hook
for your bad behavior
just because you say well I'm being
authentic because I don't think it's a
legitimate experience yeah yeah I want
to stand for something yeah that's all
I'm saying right I got you so for the
average person who's listening to this
or watching this like why should they
care about brands should they think
about brand in the context of their own
lives or how can understanding
uh brand or marketing be you know
something that you know should Garner
their attention so how do you get into
college right college is a sweepstakes
College isn't fair only 20 of the
qualified people get into any famous
college if you just say here's
everything there is about me now you
know me as well as I do please pick me a
they're not going to spend the time it's
going to take to learn everything about
you
and B it's probably not going to work on
the other hand you can choose by which
activities you narrate by which
behaviors you highlight what you will be
seeing in the four minutes they're
choosing to just pick you or not same
thing when you're applying for a job
resume isn't you resume is the things
you selected to show somebody that you
can honestly persist in doing
consistently so that you can get to the
next step
and the same thing is true in all the
people we connect with online and all
the people we work with we get to pick
what story people tell
about us when we show up my blog post
today is about writing your own
autobiography so the autobiography the
biography of Robert Moses is a 66 hour
long audiobook I strongly recommend it
because you can listen to it at fast
speed
so here's this guy who lived for 90
years and it took only 66 hours to tell
us about his life
which means you have to leave out all of
it except a little tiny bit which part
are you going to talk about right you're
going to talk about that evening he his
daughter had a fever and he went to the
drugstore for her no because it doesn't
add to the narrative
so what I'm saying is
you probably will benefit from writing
your own narrative and living it because
people are going to judge you one way or
the other you should be judged the way
you want to be judged
there's the story that we want to tell
others about who we are and how we show
up in the world and present ourselves so
that we can you know succeed or make our
way in the world in in the manner of our
aspirations and then there's the stories
we quietly tell ourselves think about
who we are and what we're capable of and
and those are really that that really
dictates outcomes you know in this in
the largest way and this is the ultimate
hamstring for most people myself
including and this is what your next
book is about
tell me more this is what we need you to
teach us
what do we say when we talk to ourselves
who is more qualified to talk about that
than you and I don't know maybe maybe
you no no because I don't know how to
talk to myself in a way that would
increase my performance in ways that are
outside of my comfort zone
the way that you do and I think that you
can start with physical performance
because it's easier to measure but it's
all of the same thing which is you don't
need more time you don't need more
information you need to tell yourself a
different story and rebooting the story
We Tell ourselves is really challenging
there are lots of hacks for it but
conceptually just acknowledging it's
possible
is super important and pressfield's work
goes into this without naming it but war
of Art and the new book are just all
about by acting differently you will
start to tell yourself a different story
yeah so it's the action that changes the
story but the action is the result of a
decision that has to be made correct and
that decision is a stumbling block
because on some level whatever story it
is that we're telling ourselves about
who we are and our capacity
even if it's incredibly negative and and
most people's stories are
first it's acknowledging that it's an
illusion but even more primary to that
is understanding that even though it's
not serving you it is serving you
there's a reason why you're holding on
to it there's a comfort with it correct
um it's a it's a way of of of staying
safe and small so you're not putting
yourself on the line and even if it's
obvious to everyone else and to the
person themselves it still is a
Herculean task to Grapple with that and
ultimately transcend it correct and
we've been indoctrinated intentionally
by cultural forces since the day we were
born to have this story be told to
ourselves that industrialists invented
it sure so that we would show up at work
right and this opens up the whole
conversation around education uh which
was you know constructed from an
industrialist perspective to you know
create compliant workers and to sort of
uh
[Music]
um
uh you know lure us into a web of of
easy coercion right and you have a lot
of ideas about what's wrong with
education and how it should be changed
and when you name it when you name it
it's already making people uncomfortable
yeah they don't want to believe that it
feels like something that your loving
parents put you into at the beginning
that you've been doing your whole life
must be a natural law it must be correct
and if it is working for you no problem
no harm no foul but what we are seeing
with a new generation coming up with the
climate with everything else is it's not
working for us and we are not going to
be able to standardize test our way out
of this
and understanding that well-meaning
people were part of a system of
indoctrination helps you realize what
closed the emperor is wearing and what
to do about it for yourself and for your
kids so what is the path forward if you
were you woke up tomorrow and you had
been
um you found yourself as the Secretary
of Education or some other you're in the
seat of power to you know make these
changes or you were the Provost of
Harvard or whatnot like what would you
do
well neither of those people has any
power we have a systems problem there
are people who are opening schools that
address it but most parents don't want
to send their kids there because it's
systemic
and I think we should be teaching kids
two or three things
how to lead
how to solve interesting problems and
probably how to be a good citizen how to
lead is different than how to manage how
to lead is
wayfinding pathfinding and encouraging
people to follow you even though they
don't have to and solving interesting
problems is the opposite of looking them
up in Wikipedia we don't need anyone to
know what four times seven is because we
can just look it up
what we need is for people to say oh
this is a thorny intersection of human
problems technical problems in a
situation I wonder if there's a way I
can decode this
we spend one minute a year helping
eight-year-olds and 12 year olds with
stuff like that and it extends really
dramatically into sports in school which
seems to be about solving a trophy
shortage not about helping kids lead and
solve interesting problems that was part
of the Malcolm discussion that I had
yeah yeah exactly and so when we add it
all up what we're doing is creating
people who are willing to be compliant
cogs in an industrial system and guess
what the industrial system is falling
apart so now we have all these people
who say I did what I was supposed to do
where is my American dream and we have
to say to them well actually what we
need you to do is be more insightful
than an artificial intelligence system
and be more flexible than somebody I
could hire for half the price who's
remote if you can't do those two things
I don't need you but we never taught
them how to do right after 20 years of
indoctrination in following the rules
and being a good studious individual you
become a new you are to following rules
and what we need now are people who look
at the rules and deconstruct them and
that's just not part of the curriculum
right and they're not even looking like
if you have a fever you realize you have
a fever you try to find some Tylenol in
this case people don't even know that
this system exists and that it's the
problem and so part of my work on
education has been just highlighting it
just saying look what just happened in
this classroom right here is that what
we want to do tomorrow and if not how
are we going to start undoing it and
there's a lot of interesting work
getting done in unschooling in
peer-to-peer schooling where if you say
to a seven-year-old teach this
five-year-old five things they probably
can and the seven-year-old grows the
five-year-old grows and a cycle is
created that's different
Lenny Levine the great kindergarten
teacher uh who had such an impact on my
family he said to the parents the only
purpose of his kindergarten class for
nine months is you can't say you can't
play he said your kids are all going to
learn how to read but if I can teach
them the expression you can't say you
can't play
meaning
if someone wants to join the circle they
can join the circle someone needs your
help they get your help if someone needs
leadership you lead if I can teach them
that
everything else will take care of itself
yeah but it's scary from a parental
perspective because the system and all
the external pressures that are built
into complying and adhering to that
system make it very threatening and
scary for any parent to say we're going
to opt out of that and do this when
everyone else is doing it in the
traditional way because nobody wants to
lead their child astray everybody wants
the best for their kid and it's very
easy to say well everyone else is doing
this it must be fine yep we're going to
take this risk and do this what if it
doesn't work out right back to being on
the hook right that must most Suburban
parents would like to be on the hook for
a sticker on the back of their car 10
years from now not on the hook to answer
for why their kid didn't do well on this
right and the sticker is about the
parents correct stickers about the
parents and then we say to a 17 year old
please make a decision about going a
quarter of a million dollars in debt and
base it on whether or not their stadium
makes you happy sure and not for nothing
when you're 17 you need to know what
you're going to spend the rest of your
life doing yeah which is Total Insanity
right but all of these things have
evolved in our lifetime because the
system rewards them and the more I think
about systems change the more clear it
becomes to me that the system and the
status quo remain because they're good
at remaining that there's a
self-fulfilling thing going on that
systems that didn't work disappear and
that systems that are good at hanging on
hang on and so we built all of this
insulation around the industrial system
the education system the carbon system
so they would stick around
and the only way to get rid of them is
not for the Emperor or the person at the
top to slice them open because that
never happens
it's when the Grassroots says we're not
going to deal with this anymore right
you need that Grassroots but at the same
time part of the intractability of that
problem is that the architecture of of
system stability like the the engine
behind it are the incentives right and
you can't change the system without
changing the incentives and most of the
incentives in our society are not only
holding broken systems in place
they're incredibly difficult to change
and and those can't necessarily change
at a Grassroots level it has to be from
the top down as well well so let's think
of a couple if you look at Farm
subsidies or you know anything you know
pick your but those might be the last
Domino so let's just pick a couple
trivia campaign Finance
one trivial example is no one wears a
suit to work anymore
like no one meaning 95 of the people
when I was born every person who worked
in an office wore a suit
that didn't take that long what happened
well it started because uh Levi's in the
Gap figured out they could make a profit
by flipping one day of the week
and then it shifted because certain
kinds of knowledge workers used software
in a way that created so much value they
got to announce what they were doing in
a different class of knowledge worker
came along who wasn't an investment all
right and on and on and so bit by bit it
starts to fall apart or a pandemic shows
up which is a crisis and Zoom is ready
for it the technology is present and all
of a sudden we're dismantling one of the
biggest systems in the history of the
world right commercial real estate you
don't have to go to work so you don't
want to go to work so you can work from
home well that means that they're in
giant skyscrapers in New York City that
used to be worth a billion dollars that
are empty right now and maybe they'll
never have people in them again
that there are forces that want people
to come back but people have enough
power so bit by bit systems start to
change so there's usually a disruption a
crisis a technological innovation some
sort of cultural shift that causes these
things to happen right in the case of
music
we got rock music because the transistor
radio came with headphones and before
that
everyone in the family listened to music
together
and it's headphones that permitted
teenagers to listen to music their
parents hated
and so we had to invent music that
parents would hate so that teenagers
could act out and the headphones were
the tool that changed the entire music
industry and then go fast forward 30
years MTV is doing its thing but then
rap music shows up and there's another
way forward and our friend Rick Rubin
walks right into that and begins to
change just a little tiny Corner which
gets bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and then radio falls apart so
then the Billboard charts don't matter
anymore and so yeah systems change in
surprising ways but usually because a
bunch of people can outline how and why
it should change yeah there's something
placating about that also though because
it's Reliant upon some kind of
technological innovation or it's about
some outlier creative who expresses
themselves in a certain way that shifts
culture which can create
paralysis for that Grassroots movement
it could but I think there's plenty of
for if we talk about technology the
thing that's going to change education
is for example every course at MIT is
online for free right but here's the
thing
the the pandemic presented an
unbelievable opportunity for that
seismic shift we saw it in the workplace
we really didn't see it in education it
snapped back to where it was Scott
Galloway talks about this quite a bit
here was this massive opportunity where
these institutions of Higher Learning
could have broadened their enrollment
and created tiers of Education
experience for people as public servants
but these brands are so powerful it's
back to Brand right like except they're
not Stanford whatever they have to
protect their brand and that brand is
built upon exclusivity oh yeah and
limiting enrollment we I mean they're
sitting outside
Scott and I agree about a lot of this
but I don't agree that it is ever going
to be led by Harvard or Yale what's
already happening is a self-taught
computer programmer who uses stack
Overflow for two hours two hours a day
for two years can go get a six-figure
job sure and this is this is happening
right now it's it's it's all going to
the re-emergence of and uh and the
respect for trade correct and the other
thing that's going to happen which is
already happening is third tier college
is going to go bankrupt they're gonna go
bankrupt all of a sudden and widespread
because they don't have big endowments
and people aren't going to be willing to
go in debt for the rest of their life to
get a second or third rate degree that
isn't worth anything so once that
happens then you have this cratering
underneath and all of a sudden people
are going to start like I just got a
note today applications at the top five
business schools of all the famous ones
are down between 15 and 25 percent in
one year
that's crazy but not surprising
because a whole bunch of people are
saying I don't want to become an
industrial middle manager right I don't
need to go to Wharton I'm going to go do
a thing with the hundred thousand
dollars I saved and the status of that
degree
can drop really fast as soon as the
people who are gauging the status don't
care about it anymore
I wonder if there is a downside to that
in that
what we need is you know people who are
excited about things like stem and
instead we have a generation of young
people who would rather
try to be a Kardashian or a Tick-Tock
influence there's so many doubts and
feeling like they could you know make a
ton of money overnight the easy way
thank you and the creativity and the
hard work that is part and parcel of
becoming good at anything oh the the
downsides of this shift are huge I'm not
a Pollyanna about it they're huge and
anti-intellectualism is a problem as
well as anti-smart is a problem
and Harvard is going to have to respond
or react and they have enough money to
do it they're just never going to go
first and
um you know the idea that you're going
to make it as an influencer is
fundamentally absurd you're not just do
the math
and having a skill that creates value is
a no-brainer the thing is can you get
the skill without the piece of paper
and the online workshops that I built I
don't run them anymore
um
that's what we said certainly you can do
that we can prove it now more than ever
yeah and so as soon as the value of the
paper goes down but the skill goes up
someone's going to step into that Gap
and say here's how we're going to
accredit skills as opposed to a credit
scarcity so this is all happening not
fast enough but you just need to see it
first as somebody who has such Keen
observational skills and and has your
finger on the pulse of of the macro and
can kind of see the forest for the trees
um and and your your understanding
around like how ideas spread I'm
interested in your perspective around
what has transpired culturally over the
last few years with respect to the
nature of public discourse the increase
of siloization the death of nuance the
obfuscation of Truth the ascent of the
conspiracy all of that like it's very
um
trepidatious terrain right now yes it is
so how how are you making sense of this
okay so I there are a couple of things
um that are worth noting uh the first
one is back at the dawn of the internet
I was a techno Optimist give everybody a
microphone
things get better when you get rid of
Gatekeepers and we will see a
flourishing like we've never seen before
and let me just put a pin in that for a
moment when you say the birth of the
internet you're talking about like 1976
right you're talking about arpanet 76 is
when I got my I got my first email in
76. now I'm talking about the dawn of
Prodigy I had Prodigy's most popular
product in 1989 right so we were sitting
in rooms saying this is clearly going to
get bigger and what will happen when it
gets bigger
what we failed to take into account is
some people want to be a troll
that there is satisfaction for some
people in being a contrarian that's
number one and number two is fights sell
tickets
and that's always been true
when you combine those two things what
we see is that media channels which also
have influence over technology because
Facebook is a media channel and a
technology
um have an incentive to amplify trolls
and so what you end up with is people
who make money from division
and then you have people who would like
to seek political power who make money
from division
and a cycle a non-virtuous cycle that
just keeps going in that direction over
and over and over again making it feel
like things are far more divided and
atomized than they ever were before
when in fact
what we've really done is just put
microphones in front of people who
already were angry and felt left out but
we couldn't hear them
and what happens is if you turn down the
volume of these people who would seek to
make us feel uncomfortable so that we
will go back just to make sure
everything's okay
you realize that an enormous amount of
progress has been made an enormous
amount of areas that the percentage of
the truly poor honored percentage-wise
smallest it's ever been there's still
way too many people that the ability
that we have to know things to connect
to things to learn things never before
have we seen this so what we've got to
figure out now how to do is change the
incentives for media and politicians so
that they don't make a living by making
things worse
and we've been through this before in uh
the early 1960s when I was born the
single best way to gain power in the
Soviet Union where the United States was
to threaten to blow up the planet
and we were 10 minutes away from the
entire planet being blown up in one hour
we figured out how to calm that down
because we know how much is at stake
until like last week but go ahead so
many things right and so
I think we got to figure out what to do
about breaking news
because no one needs breaking news we
got to figure out what to do about
people who are day trading their
emotions trying to figure out if
everything's going to be okay and the
last part of my rant is
the Baby Boomers have always made it
about the Baby Boomers in the 70s when
they were getting drafted it was all
about the draft in the 80s when it was
about you know Dad Rock and and music it
was all about that well the Baby Boomers
are all dying now
and you know I'm one of the youngest
ones and I'm in my 60s so all of a
sudden it's all about the end times it's
all about this is all over
and guess what 90 of the world isn't a
baby boomer that's so interesting this
idea Bloomer's making it all about
themselves we've controlled the media
since 1972. right not so much anymore
it's shifting yeah yeah
um there is this situation in which we
have the denigration of trust in
institutions right with media
politicians corporations
Etc and and also
we don't agree upon
a shared set of facts about what's real
and what isn't which is an even larger
kind of more macro problem and the
siloization is separating ourselves and
gamifying the discourse such that it's
about being right or it's about
signaling to your in-group that you are
a member in good standing as opposed to
grappling with the Nuance of reality and
trying to make sense of it and this I
see as you know the great existential
crisis of our time is the climate and I
promise we're going to get to this but
you know this is another great threat to
our ability to problem solve how can we
solve the climate problem if we can't
agree on reality
okay so again part of this is Amplified
by people who make a living amplifying
it
but we've never agreed about reality ten
years ago 80 of people in the United
States said they believed in angels that
Angels were real
and what's always been true is that
human beings have emotions and feelings
and stories
and science which is only a couple
hundred years old has come along and
shown us replicatable falsifiable
theories that we can say this is reality
your emotions are your emotions and
there's a gap between them and that Gap
widens and narrows over time
but
people including me believe lots of
things that aren't true
what you're highlighting I think is that
you can sell a lot of papers and raise a
lot of money by pointing out the other
team
refuses to acknowledge reality and that
our reality is right what really is
being said is we have feelings we have
feelings about winning and losing
feelings about status feelings about
affiliation feelings about being in
something and we will find facts in
quotation marks to prove that our
feelings are correct because people
don't like to acknowledge that their
feelings
are not correct so small side I used to
get upper respiratory colds because I
traveled so much and I walk into a
health food store in a strange town and
I say to the person behind the counter I
got a bad cold do you have any placebos
and
she says I don't know if they've come in
yet and she calls to the back to the
manager do we have any placebos and they
did not want to admit that they sold
placebos that if you want to have a
fight with an acupuncturist or a
chiropractor just point out that they
have a very effective low side effect
Placebo thank you for making that they
will insist that what they do is real
and factually based so our stories are
our stories we just have to make sure
they don't hurt other people our stories
are our stories and we have to make sure
they don't hurt other people I I'm not
convinced that people care about whether
their stories hurt other people or not
not enough you don't care enough that's
our work not to prove that they are
wrong
but to create a civil society where you
can have your feelings
but we have to have a civil society that
works for all of us and there's certain
things that you just don't do can't do
because if we do them regardless of our
story or our feelings the Civil Society
itself doesn't work that's what scares
me right and I I would argue that it's
already not working on some level of
course because of that it has never
worked perfectly but yes in recent times
it's very troubling about things that
will happen in our civil society
that are based on the amplification of
stories and division by people who make
a profit doing it right we need to see
that we need to name it and I don't
think it matters
which side of Any Given story you're on
you should be able to say that sentence
in a clear way and acknowledge that it's
concrete that's sort of a segue into
into the climate issues that I want to
talk to you about solving these problems
does require consensus and this book the
carbon Almanac is an effort to create
consensus based upon scientific research
and evidence-based reality right this is
your 20th book 20th
there are 20 best sellers
but this is okay not my book it's our
book and what's interesting about it is
that on some level you can make the
argument that it is very much a
departure from your other books which
are about marketing and business and
creativity and expression Etc
um but there's another argument that it
is very much a piece with your other
work
um certainly in the kind of beautiful
artistic presentation of it but talk a
little bit about how it fits in
thematically with as a kind of extension
of the work that you've always been
doing
so uh the Earth is going to be fine
that's not the question the question is
whether people living on the earth will
be fine
and
whenever we talk about the future what
we're doing is telling a story
and the problem with the last 40 Years
of talking about the climate is the
people who've been telling a story
haven't been doing a very good job of it
and they've been waylaid and manipulated
by the people who dig things out of the
ground or want certain political
structures to stay the way they are but
the fact is the first thing most people
say who know what they're talking about
we talk about the climate is they say
it's complicated
and it's inconvenient that was even the
name of the movie and when you say to
people it's complicated and their eyes
begin to glaze over and when you say and
it's inconvenient they walk away
on top of that it's easy to feel stupid
because no matter how much you know
somebody knows more than you
so it became hard to talk about if you
can't talk about it you can't make it
better
so the purpose of this project is I
wrote my first blog post about the
climate 16 years ago didn't solve the
problem
and I haven't written too many other
posts in the 15 years in between because
I didn't feel smart I felt stupid I felt
like whatever I was going to write
people were going to say you don't know
enough
and I said well if that's true for me
probably true for other people too
and I used to make almanacs when I was a
book packager I knew how to make an
almanac I could have made the whole
thing myself if I had spent Five Years
on it but I wanted to model systems
change how do we do something together
and so 300 people 40 countries every
single page is footnoted with uh live
links on our website we correct errors
in real time we haven't corrected any
that matter and
raw volunteers including me and it
became a bestseller in the US and the
Netherlands and Italy and just came out
in China
but here's the thing that people should
take away
let's say it's 1642. and you're a James
Bond villain and you want to kill all
the whales
the way you would do it is by putting
space lasers on satellites and shooting
the whales from space the problem is
there are no satellites there are no
space lasers
so you know what you could do instead
you could teach five people that whale
oil is a really good way to light your
house
and if you did that the idea would
spread and then there would be whale oil
refineries and people who made the
lanterns and people who built the boats
and people who wanted the whales and
people who made a living building a
system
in which the input was wealth
and the only reason there are whales
left is not because people said please
please please stop hunting whales
the only reason there are whales left is
because someone invented kerosene
and then the system changed
and we have a systems problem and this
is what I learned in working on this
project learned a lot about human nature
about the amazing people I did this with
around the world but the systems problem
is simple
110 years ago there was a gusher called
spindle top
and a couple years before that they
found oil in Pennsylvania
and those two things created the modern
world
cheap energy from the ground for anybody
who wants to get up and what we've been
doing for 110 years is selling
carbon-based energy way cheaper than we
should we forgot to count how much it
really costs and so everything in the
system around us is based on cheap
energy that's underpriced and as long as
the system is based on convenience and
price and the all the other things we
built around it
we can't solve this problem by just
saying I'm composting in my backyard
yeah we need to change the system
a couple observations it really does
model the addiction Paradigm on some
level you know it's sort of flipped to
say we're addicted to cheap energy but
truly we are and what's interesting
about that is the notion that
uh we become addicted to something
because it works whether it's alcohol or
cocaine or gambling or bad relationships
or scrolling on our phone it's serving a
need and a purpose and cheap energy did
that it allowed us to modernize the
world right but it works until it
doesn't and it's not working anymore
right and it becomes a function to kind
of extend the addiction metaphor like
the elevator is going down is it going
to hit the bottom or are we going to
step off before it hits the bottom and
this is the story that every person who
struggles with addiction has to answer
for themselves and now we're having to
answer that as a global society and
um it's hard
as somebody who loves somebody who is
struggling with addiction to see them
destroying themselves to know that there
is a solution to offer your hand to help
and to see them refuse to take your hand
beautifully said and this is the
scenario that we are in right now and
the solution as you so eloquently put
cannot rest on necessarily or only the
shoulders of the individuals to Martyr
themselves or to make sacrifices that
seemingly are just a drop in the ocean
but to create the system change wherein
the right choice is the convenient
Choice the cost affordable Choice the
accessible choice for everybody correct
well set so how do we bridge that Gap
and get there
so the purpose of the almanac
is to begin to have the conversation to
answer that question because we weren't
having it
and so I have personal theories but I'm
not speaking for the almanac team the
reason is because what we did in the
almanac 97 000 words built by 300 people
fact checked completely and say you can
look up every single thing in this book
every single thing there is no argument
about any fact or you have these
three-digit codes correct for every
topic right so you go to the carbon
almanac.org and then the three numbers
and it will show you everything we use
to write if you find a mistake we will
fix it no problem
but what do I think I think there are
just a few very simple dramatic shifts
that will change the system and put the
market to work that the reason markets
have transformed the world is markets
are good at finding and solving problems
they see a need if there's a team that
doesn't have a baseball bat and they
need a baseball bat someone will figure
out how to sell them a baseball bat and
now the baseball bat problem goes away
because the market did it not some
central government Authority or some
wizard someone says I need something
someone sells it to them
that only works if the inputs and
outputs are measured properly so the
first thing hardest to implement in the
short run but it's already happening in
countries around the world is you give
every single person a check
for three thousand four thousand dollars
and you get the money for that check by
pricing carbon fairly so if you buy
exactly the same amount of carbon as you
used to buy you'll probably break even
if on the other hand you want to take a
private jet from here to London it
doesn't cost eighty thousand dollars it
costs four hundred thousand dollars if
you really want to go you can still go
but now we've charged you the correct
price and if you do that all of your
fellow citizens are going to get a
better check a bigger check because you
decided to do that right so as soon as
you do that it's called a carbon
dividend and Border adjustment
all these different decisions get make
you know those yoga mats you bought the
yoga mats aren't going to come wrapped
in a plastic bag anymore because plastic
bags are cheap in the old days now
plastic bags are expensive as they
should be in there come wrapped in paper
but if you want to buy the plastic bag
you can but why would you because it's
not convenient
and so it starts to Ripple through the
economy really fast the government
doesn't touch any of the money and what
you end up with is
corporations which run so much of our
economy making smart decisions and
consumers which run the rest of our
economy making smart decisions that's
the first part
and the second part which surprises a
lot of people is way more than 20 of our
problem maybe 35 of our problem
is cows there are a billion cows on this
planet
and it is very hard for me other than
the cost of change to understand why
anybody would say we should have any
cows on this planet most people on Earth
don't eat things that come from cows and
if everyone did eat the way we eat in
the United States just the physics of it
we would need a whole other planet just
to hold the cows so clearly that's not
going to happen because we don't have
another planet
so with that said
the path forward is pretty clear the
systems that built this now that I just
described would get rid of 70 to 80 of
the problem
if someone can figure out how to make
fusion power work that would help an
enormous amount
and what's not helping is green washing
what's not helping is people doing
performative stuff that makes them feel
like they're making a difference like
recycling their plastic water bottles
which doesn't work which was invented by
the Plastics industry and they know it
doesn't work
when you start doing those things you're
giving yourself Solace for one day
but you're spitting on your
grandchildren's yeah those those are
lullabies right designed by vested
corporate interests to uh you know make
us feel like this is all uh moving in
the right direction when in fact it's a
barrier to the solution that we need
um the cows thing people are very
dismissive of that they like to make fun
of it and there's a lot of sort of
intellectual gymnastics going on right
now to uh to suggest that you know
that's really not part of the problem in
fact we need the cows for the soil that
has been so denigrated and you know
there's a lot of there's a lot of I
think uh moral intellectual confusion
around that yes and I really don't want
to have an argument with anybody who
cares about keeping beef around I get it
that's your story those are your
feelings you can have them you just
asked when you look at the math where
it's coming from there's a great book
that people who want to approach this
problem with an open mind should read
called The Wizard and the prophet
and what he describes in its history
book it's about two men who only met
once in their life who changed the world
the wizard won the Nobel Prize for
feeding uh people in Mexico India and
other places by hybridizing seed and
killing the soil by creating the
fertilizer industry because if you put
enough fertilizer down and until you can
grow a lot more crops in the short run
he fed a billion people doing that it's
hard to be against feeding a billion
people
the prophet invented the modern
environmental movement and said we have
exceeded the Earth's carrying capacity
we need less people and we need less of
a footprint so their whole lives were
woven back and forth they just kept
missing each other and the wizard was
right and the prophet was right they're
both right and they're both wrong that
the way forward is to understand how
we're going to use technology to create
the conditions for carbon to get back in
the topsoil how are we also going to
tread lightly and put in uh you know
whether it's LED lights or family
planning so that we don't have 20
billion people on the planet because we
can't have 20 billion people on the
planet no matter how you do the math
so
it's complicated and the people who
don't want us to change will make it
more complicated and this is that I like
the thing I really want to focus on
because a lot of people listen to you
and some of them will be swayed by
people who want the status quo to stay
where it is so the easiest way to do it
is I need to persuade you not to get
near beef because and there's just like
a lot of math and stuff and it's easy to
say okay fine and then this person says
well how will we live a life without
plastic and but so we just need to be
alert to the fact that we can argue
about this all day but the Earth is
getting warmer every single day and a
melted ice cap never gets unmelted sure
and the wait and see approach let's just
sit on the sidelines and don't worry
about recycling because we know that
doesn't work anyway and somebody's going
to innovate our way out of this is
another form of lullaby right like we do
have to shoulder our own personal
responsibility for this and make the
conscious choices that we can it's
incumbent upon us it's is part of our
responsibility towards you know living
in this society and borrowing you know
the planet from our grandchildren and
the generations to come
um and I think what what is incredibly
frustrating about all of this is that we
already have the solutions like yes we
need Innovation but actually we already
have enough Innovation to solve all of
this like and more than half of this
book is Solutions like I think you know
maybe
30 percent into the book it turns to
Solutions and it's all about Solutions
just like I mean this book in in many
ways is similar to Paul Hawkins book
regeneration like it's like here are the
problems and look at all these people
who are already doing all these amazing
things that can solve this problem how
do we onboard these people so that their
Technologies can get traction how do we
reconfigure the incentives such that
these solution oriented
um Innovations can get integrated like
whether it's solar wind and nuclear I
know there's a lot of you know
controversy and conversation around that
but like we have everything that we need
now the only thing we do need is
political will frankly and we need
Grassroots will
and we need business incentives that are
in line and see the short and long-term
benefits for investing in these things
correct what you just described as a
marketing problem
that's why it fits in with my work we
have a marketing problem that if you
tell an investor you tell a CEO you tell
a congress person a story that's true
that resonates that's to their advantage
they will use it they will move in that
direction we have done a bad job because
of the wizard profit confusion of
letting the status quo persist because
their stories are better because they
got really good at it so Ogilvy the
famous Ad Agency invented the term
carbon footprint
and their client with British Petroleum
it's one of the great marketing
campaigns of all time because if you are
worried about your carbon footprint you
feel like a hypocrite if you feel like a
hypocrite you're not going to talk about
it um
yeah that's super interesting
um the Exxon memo like I flagged it in
here
it's like on page 46. I can't wait till
they sue us it would be great I mean
first of all so all right there's in the
book you have a photocopy of a memo from
Exxon dated November 12 1982. in which
Exxon proceeds to basically describe the
very problem that we're experiencing
right now in 1982 and they got to a to a
degree get this memo they predicted
exactly what the climate would be like
today in that memo and I it the great
cartoonist uh Randall Monroe linked to
it in one of his XKCD cartoons so that's
how I found it I don't know how it where
it came from the internet but it is a
genuine thing Exxon has not denied that
these are their words from one of their
engineers
I was wondering why it didn't you didn't
just put it like right on the page one
insert to the book at the very beginning
because it's so damning and
extraordinary to read this yeah I we had
a lot of decisions to make in five
months about the book
it's easy to make a book that's filled
with shame and blame and villains yeah
and it's also easy to make a book that's
completely positive all this I mean what
what do you want to do and so the team
was terrific in figuring out how to not
use balance as an excuse to not mean
anything but to use it as a way to say
there is nobody you can put you can give
this to who can say I reject this out of
hand because we're not showing up to
punch somebody in the face we're showing
up to say the weather in Central Park is
not up for debate this is what the
weather is in Central Park right now
what should we do about it is Up For
Debate so let's have conversations about
what to do about it because the time is
long gone to deny it if explain why you
felt compelled to create this book in an
almanac format and and like what is an
almanac actually it just feels like you
know when I think of Almanac I think of
like Benjamin Franklin yeah he was he
was first
um
almanacs changed my life when I was a
book packager because I uh invented the
business Almanac and it sold a lot of
copies it was the internet before the
internet
and then we did the celebrity Almanac
with People magazine and I did the
women's Almanac and I love them because
they match the way my brain works even
before the internet but once the
internet shows up all anyone can deal
with is an almanac half a page at a time
oh look here's a cartoon wait there's a
puppy and so
people way better at writing than me
have written articulate books about the
climate what I could add value is by
organizing a bunch of people to say yeah
but look it up here it is it's not the
encyclopedia it's not school it's an
almanac and it's got stats and graphs
and charts and it's cheap and you should
buy five and share them because if you
hand this around the office then
tomorrow you can say which page do you
think we should discuss because we got
to discuss something
um
part of the the kind of cultural
battle that we're waging right now is
one between Liberty and responsibility
and Liberty is winning there is
something very American ingrained in our
DNA as citizens of this country
that
over indexes on Liberty and we've seen
the flare-ups politically and culturally
around that right now and what were what
were not valuing to the extent that is
you know necessary right now is the
counterbalance delivery which is
responsibility this is something that
was kind of understood in Prior
Generations when World War II happened
Etc and I feel like that is lost right
now in the conversation and in the kind
of approach that we have towards
how we feel about this country that we
live in in this planet that we're
sharing so how do we restore
a a return or at least a a call back to
feeling a shared sense of communal
responsibility because ultimately you
know this is what the almanac is saying
it's like yes we need system change but
we also need individual responsibility
and change
yeah this is um I wish I had a glib
answer I will tell you a couple
interesting things about going to some
of the poorest places on Earth
I've worked with Acumen for more than 20
years Jacqueline is one of my heroes
she's unbelievable she's a very special
person
um they have now helped 200 million
people around the world who are the
poorest people in the world who make
three dollars a day and start to move
their way out of poverty but one of the
things you notice when you're in one of
those places is no one's on a weird diet
because you don't have that much food
anyway
you have to have a lot of food available
you have to have a Whole Foods down the
street before you can say no I only eat
collagen from left-handed animals or
whatever it is right
and the other thing that goes on is
there's an enormous amount of freedom
from government intervention in places
like this you don't have to pay any
taxes and there's nobody from the
government who's going to come tell you
what to do and yet
most people wouldn't want to live there
given the choice because the Creature
Comforts the civilization that we have
come to expect
is important and it's so easy to take
for granted
so Liberty is a fascinating term because
Liberty requires Civil Society for it to
be worth anything whatsoever
so I think we have to be careful making
sure that the dichotomy is in between
Liberty and responsibility because I
think you can't have Liberty unless you
have responsibility that's sort of its
definition
with that said
um there
are long histories of shocks to the
system that lead to changes in the
culture
and you know the Beatles were shocked to
the system that aided by technology
changed the culture
and I think we are facing now a massive
shock to the system
that the fact is that you know what I
don't know what the expression is
there's no atheist in a foxhole
that when your house is flooded
you start to think a little bit
differently about whether we should be
doing something about whether it's going
to get flooded again
and like I learned in the current you
can't really easily fight the current to
the Pacific Ocean and you can't really
easily fight the weather
fighting the weather is really expensive
and I think it's going to cause a shift
in our culture but those problems are
academic and obscure until you find
yourself mired in them right and the
human
animal is not wired very well to contend
with future problems that are not
experiential in the moment right so it's
happening and it's gonna the next year
is going to be so much worse than last
year
we still have 10 years to take dramatic
action and my hunch is that we're going
to soon hit a point where it's obvious
and where it's enough enough for people
to say oh not that I was wrong based on
what I knew then I was right but now I'm
going to make a new decision based on
new information and this is what we
should do mm-hmm
yeah there's a quote in the book
convenience is all destination and no
journey and a lot of
these problems at least from our
experiential perspective are the result
of overabundance and convenience where
we're not contending with real problems
that are being visited upon us now and
as such we have to focus on trivialities
right and the threat of our conveniences
being taken away from us is really you
know monopolizing our Focus instead of
allowing us to focus on the real
problems yeah and I think
the grown-ups who are listening to us
today
are aware enough that they ought to be
able to say there is a difference
between your feelings and the way things
are almost always
where we get into trouble is when we
insist that the way things are have to
match our feelings because we always
start with our feelings you're entitled
to your own feelings you're not entitled
to your own science
and as somebody who understands deeply
how ideas spread what is your sense of
you know beyond the almanac and the
resources Etc and for this movement as a
whole what is something we could all
think about and practice that could help
these ideas spread
so I've been studying how ideas spread
longer than most people and I still
don't understand I'm pretty good at
being able to point to something and say
yeah that one's going to work and
sometimes I'm right but then things come
out of the blue and totally
don't make any sense until after the
fact right and
I don't know what the dynamic is going
to be that causes this one to give
people the status roles the affiliation
the energy to make it easy to spread it
will because the same way the internet
did right that people didn't know that
email was going to be the killer app
they didn't know that chat was going to
be the killer app they didn't know that
Facebook was going to work when
Friendster didn't
but then something happens and it's a
very complicated formula but there is
something happens and it's happened
quickly it sometimes it happens quickly
sometimes it takes longer but
this is happening now a year ago when I
started this people gave me a funny look
and now like oh of course
it and that happened not just in New
York that happened with people who I
know in Perth and people I know in
Johannesburg and people I know in
Bangalore
it's on the radar and it's not a fad
why don't we have some kind of Manhattan
Project under maybe we do I don't that I
don't know about but how come we don't
have the brightest people in the world
convening regularly to solve this
problem at the highest level well
because we get confused about what the
highest level means the highest level
for war has always been Dr Strangelove
in the Pentagon
but the highest level for the kind of
technological cultural change we're
talking about has always been privately
funded entities
and the internet took off when 20 people
on Sandhill Road decided it was the best
investment they ever saw
and I was there and if you had a notion
it became an idea and then the next day
it was a business and then you had the
resources to share and what I am seeing
I one of the reasons I'm out here is I
spoke at a regen conference a VC fund
that only funds companies that are
working on this problem that the first
trillionaire is going to be somebody who
comes up with a really substantial
impact on this problem
so that's not enough because we need the
carbon border adjustment and dividend we
need
all the stuff that the people we elect
can do but they always follow they never
lead
and so they're going to follow us if we
show up enough times if the first second
and third question anyone running for
any office gets asked is about the
climate not true yet but it's starting
to happen and they ultimately need to be
responsive to the people who are going
to send them money or send them votes
and that's going to happen when we speak
up so yeah there's the number of
brilliant people who are working on say
Fusion
10 times what it was 10 years yeah yeah
and the money should get funneled into
the innovators who are making that
correct conscious Choice be not just the
the
um the Easy Choice and the affordable
choice but also the sexy choice right
like I love how on the website for this
the first thing in terms of like a call
to action for anybody who's visiting is
switch your your browser to this ecosha
and for every 45 searches they plant a
tree and they've planted I don't know
however like a lot of trees millions and
millions which is like I've never had
heard of that what a great idea it's so
cool there's no friction to making that
switch it's very easy and you can be
part of the solution and it's cool and
you feel better about doing your
searches exactly the status goes up
there are no ads it's more convenient
and if everybody switched it would be
the equivalent of taking I don't
remember the number a lot of cars off
the road it's a very significant they
thought the answer to the problem but
what's really interesting is
the resistance some people have to
switching and I got one email talking
about placebos this person said I used
to use Bing I switched to a cosia
because I like your blog but I'm
switching back because Bing has
different better results
and I wrote to them and I said did you
know that ecosia is powered by Bing and
the results are exactly the same
and you know you never hear back from
people like that but the point is we
tell ourselves the story right and
what's happening is once you start
telling yourself the story of I am going
to make these shifts you can't start
untelling yourself because there's so
much momentum the same way in 1995 a
whole bunch of people said this internet
thing's never going to amount to
anything but some people got an email
address and some people got a geocities
page and then and it unravels or ravels
forward and
so I'm guardedly optimistic human beings
can screw up just about anything human
beings are capable of being really cruel
and short-term thinkers
but
a lot of people have privilege
don't want to have privilege in a world
that's not worth living in and they're
starting to show up either because
they're going to make more money or
because they want to undo some of the
damage that nuclear privilege cost
in in the the Journey of compiling all
of this and working with all of these
experts and researchers what was the
most surprising fact or truth that was
uncovered as somebody who already was
steeped in this science I would say the
most stunning is the carb is that
plastic recycling is a fraud
intentionally invented to trick us it is
chemically impossible to have blue bins
filled with plastic be recycled and
almost everywhere they're just put in
the incinerator and all you've done is
make the incineration more efficient
and said that boldly people are sort of
amazed and then the next day they will
still put plastic in the blue bin
no no blue bins at the at the golden
household well in half the golden house
yeah blue bins uh and then the other one
that just a surprising trivial fact
concrete is eight percent of the problem
right blew me away yeah you have those
like four C's at the beginning of the
book yeah I had no idea I thought that
was fairly benign thing concrete is
cement heated to more than 2 000 degrees
by coal usually
it to make concrete and so we got all
these coal plants that are belching
carbon into the air it's like crack
cocaine for the atmosphere so that we
can make more concrete and the good news
is there's been in that space yeah like
there's all these new uh building
materials that are actually better
lighter more structurally sound right
that obviate the concrete problem and as
soon as we start charging the right
price for coal it will just happen
instantly but right now right there are
still entities say yeah but it's cheaper
to do it the old way
um Robert Downey Jr just built this new
house and it made the newspaper out here
it made the news and it's like I don't
know what the name of the the building
materials are but it's it's kind of like
this curved structure it's very kind of
flintstoney meets the Modern Age kind of
thing but apparently there's something
about it I should know more if I'm going
to talk about it I don't know that much
about it but my friend Darren is also
using the same materials to build a home
right now as well uh and it it's
completely carbon neutral yeah and we
don't think of our building we know
about lead and green buildings and all
of that but it's not a you know it's not
immediately obvious like why building a
building would be a problem yeah so
here's a great systems example
uh in my little town leaf blowers are
against the law six months of the year
and the reason is one hour of using a
leaf blower puts out as much carbon as
driving a Toyota Camry from LA to New
York
that's nuts by true
and they're noisy and they're not good
for the people who are using them
so systems idea number one it only took
20 people in my town to get them banned
pretty easy to get a band like that pass
because people can get an electric leaf
blower it's no big deal number two
the long contractors in my town
persist in forcing their underpaid under
respected workers to use gas Leaf floors
they just like either don't pay the
tickets or they pay the tickets it's
more convenient to keep doing it the old
way
and if it's this hard to change leaf
blowers when it's so obvious about their
problems and so easy to replace it with
something that's quieter better and more
efficient
you can see the scale of our systems
problem and the way we solve it is by
saying guess what if you're a contractor
in town and you get three tickets you
don't have a permit anymore
and then in one day for all the gas leaf
blowers would be gone yeah well if we
care if you're listening to this and you
care figure out how to get that law
passed in your little town
once enough little towns passed the law
they'll stop making gas leaf blowers and
we will move on to the next thing yeah I
mean it's it's it's back to incentives
yep right same with like
solar on our homes if we had better
incentives more people would grapple
with that and figure it out yeah
and no one wants to go back right nobody
says oh my house is filled with
beautiful LED light I'm ripping it out
and putting it incandescent and nobody
says oh I'm getting reliable solar power
off the grid I wish I could plug back
into the coal plant down
it's pretty clear that we have figured
out a path they're going to have test
tube meet soon so if that's your thing
you can eat real hamburger all you want
right but
first we gotta have forward motion and
systemic change which comes from talking
about it and it's uh it's there's a
ticking clock that's the other thing
indeed you know so in the uh you know
Robert McKee screenplay like where are
we are we nearing like the bottom of the
second act right now like where do we
find ourselves on the the Doomsday
timeline yeah no we've the inciting
incident has already come and gone right
it allows that's page 10. yeah so we're
well past that exactly you know I think
it's worth reminding ourselves that
we're all gonna die
Americans don't like to acknowledge this
but we're all going to die
so
you're either going to die in 10 years
or 50 years or 100 years but we're all
going to die so how do we live a life
that we're proud of along the way
and rather than handicapping how bad is
the earth going to be in 10 years or 15
years I think what we have is the chance
to shift our time frame
and to say if we're lucky enough to have
all of the Bountiful benefits that
technology has given us and we've got
food on the table and a roof over our
head Isn't Our obligation to just
respond to that by making our time zone
our time Horizon at least a couple weeks
longer as opposed to just what's on TV
tonight 100
um enrollment is a big theme for you
right and it seems like enrollment is
germane and pertinent to this issue
so maybe we can kind of
end this with some thoughts about
enrollment and how to get people more
actively engaged
so enrollment is another word that's
easily confused because you enroll your
kid in school because you have to that's
not what I'm talking about if you're a
bus driver and your bus goes from here
to Santa Fe
it doesn't pay for you to go up and down
the streets trying to persuade people
that they should go to Santa Fe
right that if somebody really wants to
go to Bakersfield they should get on a
different bus your bus goes to Santa Fe
and we don't need a unanimous vote here
on almost any marketing plan but
including the one about our planet all
we need to do is be able to find the
people who want to go to Santa Fe who
are enrolled in the journey organize
them connect them and amplify them
there's already enough
that you can change the Constitution of
the United States without a vote if you
build a non-profit that sticks with
their idea for 40 years 40 Years of
sticking with it and sticking with it
then you get your justices and you win
it's not what's the crisis of today it's
not about being a slacktivist it's this
is the bus we're on and so it's not
going to take 40 years what we need to
do is shun the non-believers and say to
people oh okay not for you but it is for
these people these people you respect
these people you want to be friends with
these people who are leading they're all
getting on this bus and the bus is going
this way here we go and if someone wants
to get off the bus they can get off the
bus because we can't force them but what
marketing is in this day and age is not
that you have one third of the channels
viewers tuned to your channel what it is
is that you incrementally build how many
people are on the bus and you connect
them to each other and then you amplify
their work and you empower the leaders
and the leaders need to carry themselves
with a certain level of responsibility
mixed with Charisma and something about
them that is aspirational that makes
people want to get on board that's right
and the good news is you don't need one
leader because it's not an election all
shapes and forms exactly you don't like
Greta we got Seth right over here well
I'm the do not belong in the same
sentence
well I commend you for this really
important work
um it's really a beautiful Act of
service thank you you are a genius
teacher uh I aspire to your level of
clarity and thought and your Precision
with language uh it is the high water
mark for me and I have so much respect
for
everything that you're about the extent
to which you make yourself available as
as a teacher as a mentor as a
as somebody who who is a Creator who
thinks deeply about what the right thing
to do is and tries to make the world a
little bit of a better place that is
your promise to the people that care
about what you do and I think you're
fulfilling in that promise and I'm
staring at this outline that's like 20
pages long and we got to about 10 of
that so I hope that we can continue this
was such a conversation yeah I can't
wait to do it again maybe we'll have to
do it by Zoom if that's okay but a
pleasure no I think I just have to go up
to HOH okay we'll we'll go out and do
that in the meantime I would also
encourage people to check out the series
of podcasts that you have done with both
Tim Ferriss and Brian koppelman those
are all wonderful and we'll provide you
with a background until we reconvene and
there's a hundred and you've done 200
episodes of akimbo with no guests right
it's just really rattling on and it's
really yeah we didn't even talk about
your podcast that was in the outline but
I've been enjoying that it's very
different different from most podcasts
out there they're sort of little like
sort of mini blog uh Rants and thoughts
and truths mixed in and it's very
entertaining thank you yeah I really
enjoy this was such a pleasure thank you
for having me appreciate it thanks Seth
cheers peace
[Music]
foreign